[Musique]
vous avez fait le test tous les deux oui
il y a environ 3 ans on est positif
cétait un peu comme si on menlev un
poid j'ai mis au point ce programme
pourner foi en l'amour plus
d'incertitude plus besoin de se demander
si on est avec la bonne personne plus de
divorce nous avons éé les premiers à
acheter la machine pour réaliser le
testin de renforcer le sentiment
d'amour j'ai très vie de travailler
ici il y a un tas de gens célèbres qui
sont passés par là-bas ah oui comme qui
Ginger Spice c'est ma préférée oui je
sais tu vas être formé par Amir c'est
déjà l'un de nos meilleurs instructeurs
quelle est la chose que vous aimez le
plus chez Maria prenez votre temps
j'adore ses
cheveux ils sont doux et brillants c'est
une jolie réponse très jolie on le sait
tous la solitude nous fait souffrir
c'est terrible et on cherche tous
désespérément à combler ce vide je peux
te demander quelque chose pourquoi
est-ce que tu travailles à l'Institut
pour comprendre un peu mieux
[Musique]
l'amour je suis curieuse de voir à quel
point ces exercices peuvent aider à se
rapprocher pourquoi on fait ça je
croyais que ça nous amuserait c'est
juste un peu
dégoûtant tu sais au bout d'un moment
c'est normal de tomber dans une sorte de
routine je crois que pour qu'un couple
fonctionne il faut faire des efforts oh
pardon désolé je me demandais si c'était
éventuellement possible qu'une personne
obtienne un résultat positif avec deux
personnes différentes biologiquement
c'est impossible oui c'est ce que je me
[Applaudissements]
disais j'ai quelque chose à
[Musique]
t'avouer
only
you